su majestad la reina que lleva 70 años
en el trono es la única monarca que
conoce el 98 por ciento de los
británicos no habían nacido cuando su
padre el rey jorge era era el jefe del
estado entonces estos 70 años la han
llevado a convertirse y mucho más allá
de lo que significa un jefe de estado es
un símbolo de la unión del país es un
símbolo del país es la marca el reino
unido por excelencia es muy complicado
imaginarnos a reino unido si mis abel y
a isabel sin reino unido aunque
dentro de relativamente poco vamos a
tener que acostumbrarnos a esa imagen
ahora mismo la reina isabel es el norte
de la brújula de los británicos es la
única certitud que tienen los británicos
como decíamos antes no van pasando los
primeros ministros laboristas
conservadores
se unieron a la unión europea tuvo lugar
el break sheet los presidentes los eeuu
también van cambiando hasta los papas en
roma' van cambiando pero los británicos
estos 70 años
han tenido esa es a esa certitud ese
faro esa guía que era la reina isabel es
un icono universal
la reina isabel es un caso único en los
jefes de estado internacionales porque
aunque es verdad que no es el récord de
longevidad en monarcas internacionales
sí lo es con la fuerza que tiene la
imagen de la reina isabel conocida en
absolutamente todos los rincones del
mundo es marca gran bretaña en estado
puro así es muy bien también como usted
lo estaba diciendo vamos a tener que
acostumbrarnos en un futuro no tan
lejano digamos a que la reina isabel ya
es esa su función es digamos como la
soberana no como la monarca la reina
del reino unido sobre esa sobre esa
premisa pues que quería hablar qué va a
pasar
ella aplicará digamos a quien a su hijo
el príncipe carlos oa su sobrino
algo así sobrino el asesor y uno en a su
nieto perdón el príncipe harry y hay a
kate middleton que va a pasar allí
william el príncipe en principio
sería tremendamente
sorprendente que es una gesta de la
reina isabel abdicar a esto no no es lo
esperado lo esperado es que su majestad
fallezca si me permiten con la corona
apuesta
una vez fallecida la reina lo esperado
lo marcado por la constitución es que la
corona pase a manos de su heredero
directo el príncipe carlos pero
recordemos que el príncipe carlos es a
su vez también una persona de avanzada
edad entonces su reinado no sé si será
más largo o más corto depende de
la ley de la naturaleza
pero sí que será un reinado por fuerza
mayor que va a tener que ser muy apoyado
por el
príncipe guillermo y su esposa catalina
porque el príncipe carlos va a acceder
al trono a una edad de la que la mayoría
de sus conciudadanos la mayoría de los
británicos se está jubilando de su
puesto de trabajo
entonces
no va a tener la fuerza no va a tener la
vitalidad quizá no va a tener la salud
como para viajar por todos los países de
la commonwealth tal y como se espera de
un soberano británico
entonces es el reinado de carlos sea más
largo o sea más
va a tener que estar muy muy muy apoyado
por la siguiente generación que son los
actuales duques de cambridge entonces
cuando el príncipe carlos sea nombrado
rey de inglaterra ellos pasarán a ser el
príncipe y la princesa de gales
marina y es que eso le quería preguntar
yo yo le decía eso porque llama la
atención que no es su hijo no el
príncipe carlos quien se encargue de
estas labores él parece poco ham sino su
nieto el príncipe el príncipe william
con kate middleton realmente pues
constitucionalmente le correspondería
asumir el trono a su hijo pero cuál
sería el deseo real de la reina
lo desconocemos absolutamente
una de las una de las características
que hace que la reina sea tan regia es
que nunca se sabe lo que está pensando
nunca se sabe lo que está pensando lo
hemos visto en
millones de fotografías en millones de
imágenes
saludando a esos 14 primeros ministros
que ha tenido de todo tipo desde winston
churchill hasta hasta el actual primer
ministro son personas absolutamente
diferentes con creencias políticas
diferentes la reina siempre sale
sonriendo a su lado con gesto sobrio con
gesto regio pero siempre sonriendo nunca
sabremos o de momento no sabemos que el
primer ministro le gustaba más cuál le
gustaba menos igual que tampoco vamos a
saber
si prefiere que la suceda carlos o
prefiere que la suceda guillermo yo
entiendo como experta en la realeza
británica
entiendo que la reina es una mujer que
respeta las costumbres respeta las
tradiciones que están absolutamente
imbuidas en su persona yo entiendo que
ella desea que la suceda carlos tal y
como está previsto
marina también ahora sí hablemos de
otros dos protagonistas que no están en
que yo he estado confundido entre
guillermo y harry hablemos ahora así del
príncipe harry y su esposa may con
marcus cómo ha cambiado esto digamos a
la familia real británica no
vamos a ver la decisión del príncipe
harry el hijo pequeño de carlos de
inglaterra
el hermano del futuro rey guillermo de
abandonar su papel activo en la
monarquía británica para que nos
entendamos de dejar de trabajar para su
abuela la reina isabel
fue un golpe duro un golpe complicado
fue un momento muy difícil para la
institución pero pero se han recompuesto
rápidamente a nivel institucional no
supone mucho problema porque es verdad
que aunque a nivel mediático ocupó todas
las portadas de los principales medios
de comunicación hubo horas y horas en
tertulias en medios sobre esta decisión
y sobre el futuro de los duques de esas
ex realmente a nivel institucional es un
cambio menor el príncipe harry es el
sexto en la línea de sucesión a la
corona británica está muy alejado
la reina en cuestiones dinásticas
entonces realmente no es un cambio tan
grande
es más la repercusión mediática que tuvo
esta separación y luego bueno por
supuesto la entrevista bomba con ophra
winfrey las declaraciones de ambos
etcétera pero a nivel institucional la
institución está totalmente protegida es
un cambio insignificante podríamos decir
por por lo alejado que está harry y sus
hijos del trono o la sucesión dinástica
está garantizada a través de carlos a
través del príncipe guillermo y a través
del príncipe jorge hijo de guillermo y
catalina y no no hace daño a la
institución otra cosa es la tormenta
mediática que ha tenido que capear
buckingham palace pero sobre todo más
que con la decisión con las
declaraciones posteriores tanto del
príncipe enrique como de su esposa megan
eso sí ha sido muy difícil claro